hello everyone and welcome back to the
second match of the gold money asian
rapid knockouts it's the
quarterfinals and it's wesley so now
versus magnus carlsen and this is game
six of their second match if you've been
watching yesterday magnus won the first
match and now wesley needs to bounce
back to
well to win to bounce back in the second
match to force tie breaks
and uh that he was able to do so uh
magnus started the second match by
winning the first game
which is already close to just you know
ending
ending the entire clash but then second
game ended in a draw and then wesley was
able to win
two of the next games on demand so he
won both with the black and the white
pieces
and he was able to force tie breaks but
in the tie breaks the first rapid game
magnus was able to win with the white
pieces and now we are in the second game
of the blitz tie breaks wesley has the
white pieces and now wesley has to win
uh in order to for uh to force
armageddon so
yeah let's see uh how the game went and
uh well
what happened so it was a really crazy
second day
uh we might uh we might check out some
of the other games but uh
there are simply too many of them to
cover all of them i decided to you know
mix it all up into this one so wesley
with the white pieces
opens with d4 and what can magnus do
because he only needs a draw here he
doesn't want to do anything crazy
we have d5 by magnus c for e6 and
now knight to c3 and a6 going for the
yanovsky variation
of the queen's gambit declined we have
captured some d5e captures and
knight to f3 now uh we have knight to f6
and now bishop to g5 so just nicely
developing pieces we have bishop to e6
and now e3 preparing to develop the
light square bishop castle and
will uh see see what happens we have
knight beat to d7 by magnus
uh and now comes bishop to d3 we have c6
and queen to c2 so just normal standard
developing moves uh
characteristic for the for the queen's
gambit declined bishop to d6
and now bishop to f4 challenging this
bishop and d6
and even though black can double up
white spawns here if you do this then
you sort of
sort of get this structure that you
often get for example in the london
system
where you don't mind the double def
point you're just gonna place the knight
on e5 and you're gonna
have a good time so instead after bishop
to f4 we have queen to c7
developing the queen now threatening to
pick up the bishop and win a pawn
so bishop captures uh we have queen
captures and h3 now
we have castles by both players and here
magnus plays
g6 we have a3 by wesley and now there is
one game in the database for queen the
e7 was played but here magnus goes
knight to e8
and it is now as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game
and wesley has some four minutes on the
clock here magnus already down to three
minutes
uh so here we have knight the a4 now
with the idea of shifting
this knight over to c5 so queen to e7
freeing up
this square for the knight so the
knights on uh d7 and d6 will be very
powerful
we have knight to e5 and now knight to
d6 and now
white has an excellent knight on e5 but
these two knights
uh really control a lot of squares here
as you can see
so uh the that that's a lot of central
squares
uh we have rook eight to e1 and now rook
a to e8 so development has been pretty
much completed
uh this knight still needs to figure out
what's what's it doing on a4
uh we rook the e2 and now bishop to f5
offering a trade of one of the
one of the bishops we have bishop
captures on f5 knight captures and
now knight back to f3 not not going for
another capture
uh because if you if you trade this then
magnus will have a much easier
uh time drawing this game and like i
said he only needs a draw to
advance into the into the semi-final so
here we have knight the d6
retreating with the knight now with
ideas of shifting the knight over to e4
uh and now rook after e1 now wesley
uh his position is fine but he doesn't
have a way of breaking through so one
thing that he can do
is he can move the knight play maybe f3
and then strike in the center with e4
which will ruin his position somewhat
but he doesn't have a choice he must go
for the win here and
uh well this is what is required so
queen to d8
uh and now knight the d2 continuing with
the plan we have rook to e7
and now f3 so weakening the position a
little bit but
you have to you you have to do it we
have knights to f5
now as soon as wesley played this the g3
square has been vacated for
for the uh black knight so knights to f5
with idea of
getting the knight over to g3 maybe uh g
for now
attacking the knight and now knights the
h4 now going to g3 wouldn't be all that
impressive if you go to g3 now then rook
g2 and well
what do you do with this knight so
instead after g4 we have knights to h4
and now wesley he could continue with e4
it's what he was going for but first uh
he decided to improve the position a
little bit with king to f2
but this doesn't improve the position so
much as it worsens it so
uh here magnus continued with uh pawn to
f5 now
uh with the idea of opening up the
f-file as the king is now on f2
uh we have king to g3 now by wesley but
now
the position is completely winning for
magnus so feel free to pause the video
here and win this game for magnus while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding what
magnus played and
that's rook captures an e3 and while
this move is fine there's even a greater
move
g5 is a nice move but even a greater one
queen to b8 check or queen to c7 check
these are deadly because now after this
check
uh you don't you don't really have a
good move if you capture the knight
then g5 with check and you can't go back
the queen covers g3
you have to go forward doesn't really
matter where you go just queen g3
now and how do you stop a checkmate
there really isn't all that
much you can do if knight f1 attack the
queen we're just gonna play rook g7
check uh king to h5 or h6 it doesn't
really matter
uh and then just queen captures on h3
will be checkmate
and if you don't after queen to b8 check
if you don't capture the knight of
course
why would you you can play f4 block the
check this way but now comes
g5 and this is just uh uh completely
winning for black now the knight is
defended
uh also you you can't capture the this
is pinned and whatever you play let's
say you play something like
let's say rook to rook to f1 uh we can
even play captures on f4 with
check and after king captures an h4 or
whatever uh just
f captures here and well uh now again
the position completely opened up
we're gonna have a very uh easy time
going after this white king
so really a nice one but magnus decided
to go uh for the more straightforward
rook captures on e3 so that doesn't
require as much calculation and this is
a blitz game
as you've seen it's quite a complicated
line so you don't want to waste like two
and a half minutes calculating and then
realizing oh no but he has
this on move 17 of the calculation
so instead rook captures an e3 saying
that okay you capture i'm gonna push f4
so this is exactly what wesley did we
have f4 with
chuck king to f2 and now magnus wins the
rook back so f captures on e3 with
check rook captures in the now queen to
c7 hoping to get the queen over to h2
but knight to f1 wesley now defends
against this
uh and the queen to f4 now so
uh just bringing the queen uh uh into
the attack
we have queen to d3 now uh as there were
there was a third attacker to the f3
square now the queen is added here to
help out with the defense
and now b5 just harassing this knight on
a4
uh it's not as much as harassing us
helping it to get back into the game
but you know it's blitz so knight back
to c3
and now knight the c5 again magnus uh
finding these moves uh
you know in great style as this is a
blitz game
uh so the the queen is under attack and
you can't really move the queen away
from the defense of the f pawn because
then well
black just wins very easily so he has to
play d captures on c5 but now
d4 again with a double attack so rook to
e7
and now first f captures an e3 with
check this is what magnus wanted he
wanted to simplify the position
so uh he could minimize the possibility
of him losing
in any way uh you know uh rather than
just going for
for a fancy win like we've shown with
with maybe queen to b8 or queen to c7
so here queen captures an f3 with chuck
rook captures with czech king e2 and
only now grabbing the piece back we have
d captures on c3
b captures and rook captures on c3 and
now the position is
well what's on the board magnus is up
upon
uh but he doesn't really care uh he only
needs a draw to advance uh to the
semifinals
and uh uh well it's very very
hard for for him to lose this actually
but it is possible so here
knights to d2 by wesley knights the g2
now he can always
grab the pawn so he's not in a rush or
also this is now
free for grabs we have knights the e4
attacking the rook and not
knight to f4 now with check we have came
to d2 and
only now rook the d3 check king c2 and
the rook captures on h3
so what do you play here we have knight
to f6 check luckily uh
you can even go here you're not getting
checkmated because the rook here covers
the h7 pawn
but king to f8 and now comes rook to c7
uh going after this pawn uh we have
knight the e6
attacking the rook here and now knight
captures on h7
with check so the rook defends this it's
possible to play this
kink the e8 ending now knight to f6 with
check we have king to d8 attacking the
rook and now
rook to d7 with check king to c8 and
now rook to d6 attacking the pawn and
the knight
we have knight to d8 magnus is able to
defend the pawn and
now knight to g8 so the position is
still quite complicated
uh but uh it's very very hard for for
wesley to look for a win here we have
rook captures on a3
uh rook captures on g6 now wesley also
with the past
g pawn and now rook to e3 uh we have
rooked the g7
uh and now knight the e6 attacking the
rook and the pawn
so rook to g6 and now of course not
capturing and allowing rook captures
you're going to lose the knight so first
king the d7 defending the pawn and the
knight
uh and now knight to f6 with check king
e7 we have knight to h5
and only now rook to e5 with a double
attack on the c5
pawn rook to h6 and now magnus grabs it
rook captures on c5 and now it's three
pawns against one
it's still possible to lose this it has
happened before so magnus still needs to
be very careful if he wants to go to the
semi-finals
king the b2 was played now comes rook to
e5 we have knights to g3
now knight to d4 we have rook to h7 with
check king to d6 and now rook the h6
with
check uh king to d5 now comes rook the
h5
trying to get this outside past pawn
maybe it's going to be faster than all
of
magnus's pawns on the queen side uh but
magnus says nope
that's that's not happening he captures
the pawn we have g captures
and now uh king the e5 not even uh
not even uh you know eager to calculate
he just uh brings the king closer to
help out with the defense of the past
pawn
and that's pretty much it king to c3 was
played but now knights to f5
wanting to exchange knights knights the
e2 wesley of course declining
c5 now uh we have knights to see one now
comes king to f6 and now magnus
completely abandons his
queenside pawns uh because he only wants
to eliminate this pawn and sure draw
and that's it he is going to the to the
semifinals with knight to d3
king g5 and now of course there's
nothing more wesley can do here knight
captures on c5 king captures
and knight captures on a6 we have b4
with
check magnus wants to give up the
material as quickly as possible to
ensure a draw as fast as possible
knight captures and now we have knight
to d4 magnus even offers the knight
but wesley says nope uh you capture my
knight and then we'll call it a draw
magnus said okay
he captured the knight and he was in
this position uh on move 68 that we had
a draw by insufficient material so
really an outstanding match magnus was
better on the first day and on the
second day
wesley really really surprised him after
after losing in the first game uh
drawing the second one then winning two
games on the man which was a
super incredible but then came the blitz
section and then
magnus was able to win the first one and
then kind of force a draw out of a
completely winning position which is
what you have to do sometimes
in order to you know make sure you don't
mess something up along the way
so that's the game uh and the match
between these two fine gentlemen hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank
nigel holloway leander mulderson happy
birthday ccp constantino buchi
uh and vlad ularu for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon i continue in the
coverage of this very nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day